bonsoir et bienvenue dans savouregarde
notre grand témoin ce soir vous le
reconnaissez c'est le génial plan cul
qui publie chez Kalman Levy graphique
sale temps pour la planète l'année 2022
en dessin on va y revenir longuement une
vie à nous croquer à croquer la société
à croquer notre quotidien et à croquer
notre monde si mal en point on va en
parler tout à l'heure on a une heure
ensemble en direct pour commenter
l'actualité de ce vendredi 20 janvier au
sommaire ce soir le couple
franco-allemand 60 ans après la
signature du traité d'élysée comment va
la relation entre Paris et Berlin après
des mois difficiles Emmanuel Macron et
ola Scholtz se retrouvent ce dimanche à
Paris pour commémorer en grande pompe
cet anniversaire la guerre en Ukraine a
déstabilisé toute l'Europe va-t-elle
casser le moteur franco-allemand ce sera
notre grand débat dans un instant et
évidemment avant de retrouver aux
alentours de 20h15 les partis pris de
nos affranchis voilà pour le programme
vous me suivez plan cul ça vous regarde
c'est parti
[Musique]
officiellement tout va bien puisqu'il
n'y a pas eu de dispute pourtant
Emmanuel Macron et Olaf scholls vont
devoir plus que sourire pour convaincre
que la page des tensions entre Paris et
Berlin et tourner on va s'arrêter ce
soir sur l'état de la relation
franco-allemande 60 ans quasiment jour
pour jour après la signature du traité
réconciliation entre nos deux pays
bonsoir Léo clim bons et merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes journaliste
correspondant à Paris du Spiegel
j'imagine que vous allez suivre de près
cette journée de dimanche entre le
Panthéon la Sorbonne l'Assemblée
nationale d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
vous dire qu'elle CP va retransmettre
toute cette journée en direct de 10
heures à 18h bonsoir Pascal Johanna
bonsoir vous dirigez vous êtes la
directrice générale de la Fondation
Robert Schuman bonsoir Patrick Martin
Genier ravi de vous retrouver vous
enseigner à Sciences Po et vous êtes le
spécialiste des questions européennes et
bonsoir Fabrice d'Almeida un historien
sur ce plateau pour revenir sur les
grands couples franco-allemand qui ont
fait notre histoire vous êtes le vice de
la faculté d'Assas l'histoire des riches
c'est votre dernière ouvrage chez plomb
Plantu en art ressorti pas mal de vos
dessins sur France Allemagne n'hésitez
pas à les commenter et à réagir quand
vous le souhaitez on va commencer par
planter le décor si j'ai bien compris ça
va pas très bien c'est Stéphane
blackovski qui va nous dire les points
de crispation entre nos deux pays la 200
secondes c'est le chrono de Blacko on
l'accueille tout de suite
bonsoir Stéphane
bonsoir Myriam bonsoir à toutes et à
tous alors
bon très bien
on est d'accord
une priorité sur ce dossier c'est qu'il
faut relativiser parce que franchement
avoir des problèmes dans son couple
c'est vraiment pas du tout quelque chose
d'exceptionnel la preuve quand vous
allez à la FNAC il y a tout un rayon qui
est consacré à ça des livres qui se
proposent de régler des problèmes de
couple vous voyez ça n'a rien
d'exception peut-être que d'ailleurs les
Allemands les Français aurait profit à
lire un couple épanoui est-ce que c'est
possible oui voilà une petite lecture
pour shots et pour Macron donc pour
résumer le couple franco-allemand c'est
un petit peu comme tous les couples au
départ de la dispute il y a un problème
de communication oui donc on était là au
mois d'octobre vous voyez ça c'était le
couple Macron Scholt à l'époque on se
faisait franchement la gueule même que
le président Macron était extrêmement
fâché il était remonté il faisait au
point d'avoir annulé un petit week-end
en amoureux qui était prévu à
Fontainebleau et qui était prévu de
longue date donc quand plus des petits
weekends en amoureux c'est généralement
que le couple est en crise vous le savez
vous l'avez sans doute éprouvé et à tel
point que bah il y a des mots qui ont
été échangés donc voilà situation
classique du couple quand le président
Macron se fâche immédiatement ça tourne
à l'engueulasse et puis les mots ont été
prononcés le problème du couple c'est
que on a beau connaître par cœur les
défauts de son conjoint de sa conjointe
on arrive jamais à s'y habituer c'est
toujours engueulade et quel est le
principal défaut des Allemands mais je
vous le dis moi ils sont égoïstes ils
sont même pas moi qui le dis c'est le
président Macron qui le dit je vais
travailler avec entre le chancelier je
pense que ce n'est pas bon ni pour
l'Allemagne ni pour l'Europe quel
s'isole et voilà l'Allemagne s'isole
elle l'ajout perso bah oui puis on a des
éléments pour le rappeler quand il y a
eu la guerre en Ukraine donc le gaz
russe est devenu hors d'atteindre pour
les Allemands qui avaient fondé toute
leur prospérité industrielle là-dessus
donc olapsule ça parcouru le monde pour
signer de nouveaux contrats sans trop se
soucier de savoir s'ils auraient des
effets pour la France pour les autres
pays mais pareil avec la Chine
et il a fait son premier voyage en Chine
perso tout seul sans trop se demander si
ça aurait des effets pour son couple ou
même pour ses relations avec les pays
européens mais bon soyons honnêtes dans
un couple les torts sont rarement d'un
seul côté donc il y a aussi des
situations inverse ou c'est plutôt les
Allemands qui seraient prêts à nous
engueuler et ça encore c'est du
classique quoi dans un couple je suis
désolé mais il y en a toujours un qui
reproche à l'autre de trop dépenser et
dans cette situation on va dire que
c'est plutôt nous les Français à qui on
nous ferait se reproche et il n'est pas
forcément imméité donc vous me demandez
comment on fait pour réconcilier le
couple franco-allemand je suis désolé
vous avez des experts mais c'est pas si
compliqué le ciment du couple tout le
monde le sait c'est les projets donc il
faut un projet quel est le projet qu'on
pourrait avoir entre le industriel va
construire ensemble aux Américains qui
sont en train de subventionner un coup
de milliard leur industrie bien il faut
faire évidemment la peau à notre propre
industrie européenne donc voilà notre
projet commun il y a une possibilité
merci
je vous rappelle que dans un couple tu
as toujours un qui un qui souffre et
autres qui s'ennuie donc je sais pas des
fois deux qui sont oui c'est vrai
est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut
montrer les dessins de planture ou pas
en même temps que on se parle ça y est
on va le découvrir avec les deux petits
camarades
s'ils peuvent faire le point on y est
voilà on vous dit qu'on s'aime avec les
autres qui disent on n'est pas convaincu
fait de plus voilà justement s'il est
sympa à dessiner je vous dis parce que
moi j'aime beaucoup dessiner Merkel
Michel il a un côté Homer Simpson que
j'aime bien voilà on s'est dit Léo clim
est-ce qu'on peut parler de crise
comment comment on peut qualifier ces
tensions aujourd'hui elles ont commencé
en octobre dernier un peu avant même sur
une échelle de 1 à 10 il va commencer le
couple selon vous 17 ans le meilleur
je
citerai à trois
parce que bien sûr on va assister ce
dimanche à on va nous expliquer tout le
contraire il y aura des gestes il y aura
des symboles bien sûr mais
si il y a pour moi il y a un problème
alors ce n'est pas du tout nouveau qui
est des crises c'est pas du tout nouveau
d'ailleurs les intérêts sont souvent
opposés entre Français et Allemand les
cultures sont on ne peut pas plus à
l'opposer aussi en Europe tout ça c'est
pas nouveau ce qui est nouveau c'est que
malheureusement il est apparu que on
était plus complètement convaincus qu'il
fallait faire l'effort pour sauter pour
remplir ce gap donc faire c'est
réellement un effort à faire et
malheureusement je pense que je dois
dire en tant qu'amant que c'est plutôt
le côté allemand qu'il fautif ah oui le
côté allemand est fautif vous le voyez
comme ça parce qu'elle Johanna au fond
qu'est-ce qui est le plus difficile en
ce moment il y a un problème sur
l'énergie Stéphane a très bien montré
les Allemands sont allés chercher du gaz
partout et du et du Pétrole ça fait
monter d'ailleurs les cours il y a un
problème sur la défense aussi les
Allemands se réarme tant mieux pour eux
mais ils achètent des avions de chasse
aux États-Unis qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qui coince le plus alors d'abord la
relation franco-allemande elle date pas
de 1963 elle avait commencé avec le
projet européen 1950 quand même on était
sur la même table des négociations
depuis
et après il y a eu un effet ce traité
bilatéral franco-allemand et le traité
bilatéral il vient dans le cadre
européen il est pas à part donc il faut
toujours remettre les choses dans le bon
ordre la craie en Ukraine a vraiment
secoué l'Allemagne dans le ses
certitudes industrielles militaire et
tout a été remis un peu en question et
donc je suis d'accord avec ce que vient
de dire Léo ils ont pris une vague de
tsunami en pleine figure et où tout le
modèle économique qui était fondé plutôt
sur une relation de confiance avec la
Russie c'était effondré et donc là il se
cherche en effet un nouveau modèle alors
que la France est beaucoup plus
indépendante à la fois militairement
énergétiquement vous savez que le mot
nucléaire est un mot qui n'est pas du
tout partagé avec nos amis allemands
donc en effet et toute leur modèle
économique j'ai du industriels
automobiles avec la transition énergie
énergétique où on doit changer de modèle
il est il est en train de capoter et
puis il y a un fait nouveau politique
majeur en Allemagne c'est qu'avant on
avait une coalition à deux c'était
facile de s'entendre dans le couple
allemand maintenant ils sont trois
et l'attelage est assez bizarre parce
que sur tout puisqu'il faut négocier
tout en Allemagne il faut trouver à la
fois une majorité pour les questions
militaires et l'aide à l'Ukraine on voit
bien que ça patine ils sont pas les
premiers 10 ans à aider l'Ukraine alors
quand même que voilà et cette fois
affaibli le point de l'Allemagne au sein
de l'Allemagne ne peut ne peut ne peut
sortir enfin les chancelier il faut
qu'ils disent quelque chose qui est qui
sort de la de la collision et et à la
limite de de ce qui peut avoir trouvé
comme majorité au Bundes alors essayons
maintenant de de qualifier la gravité
des problèmes qui se posent entre la
France et la main est-ce que c'est grave
est-ce que il y a toujours eu des
difficultés mais est-ce que là on a
franchi un cap on sent que la guerre en
Ukraine déstabilise mais vraiment
jusqu'aux valeurs même de l'Europe oui
alors non je pense pas que ça
déstabilise les valeurs de l'Europe mais
c'est vrai alors moi je serais peut-être
pas aussi sévère que vous en mettant une
note 3 parce que j'ai tendance à dire
qu'on va toujours les relations
politiques mais ce qui compte aussi ce
sont les relations entre les peuples et
cette ce traité franco-allemand de et
d'amitié a été à une œuvre considérable
du général de Gaulle même si la
réconciliation a commencé avant lorsque
moi qui ai travaillé dans les
collectivités territoriales on voit
comment les les mers les villages les
villes les agglomérations font des
jumelles les lycées etc donc je veux
dire par là que il y a avec un véritable
succès maintenant qu'il y a à malentendu
oui il y a un malentendu dans ce que je
n'appellerai pas le couple parce qu'en
Allemagne on parle pas de couple
franco-allemand on parle de l'amitié
franco-allemand de la coopération
franco-allemande mais on ne sait pas ce
que c'est qu'un
juste une parenthèse parce que l'Élysée
il y a quelques jours on m'a dit il faut
des romantiser la relation
on va on peut se déplacer de cette image
là voilà et c'est pour ça que tandem on
parle de quoi en allemand
et c'est pour ça que tout à l'heure on
parlait de thérapie de couple vous savez
de toute façon dans un couple quand ça
ne va pas on divorce mais il est
impossible de divorcer entre la France
et l'Allemagne donc il peut y avoir des
malentendus on se met autour d'une table
des négociations on voit ce qui ne va
pas il y a déjà eu des malentendus
rappelez-vous les rapports vous êtes
historien les rapports entre Villiers
Brandt et Georges Pompidou et bien il y
avait de graves malentendus sur Lost
politique la politique à l'est et donc
aujourd'hui oui il y a des différences
sur l'énergie il y a des différences sur
l'Ukraine il y a des différences sur
l'intégration des pays des Balkans sur
ce point il a des divergences sur toute
une série de la politique commerciale
donc et sur la coopération militaire sur
l'avion de combat franco-allemand
à se mettre en place donc tout ça
effectivement il y a des malentendus il
faut donc se réunir pour tenter de
trouver des solutions à des problèmes
que nous connaissons on va en parler à
quoi peut-on s'attendre de ces discours
à venir et peut-être de ce qui pourrait
déboucher peut-être dans les mois à
venir au Conseil européen l'historien
que vous êtes va regarder ce sujet
attentivement Fabrice d'Almeida et je
vous donne la parole juste après on va
se replonger dans les archives les temps
forts de la relation franco-allemande 60
ans d'avancer mais aussi de tension
regardez ces signes Diane karcher
ils ont inventé le couple
franco-allemand le général de Gaulle et
le chancelier allemand combra d'adenaer
tout sourire à la signature du traité de
l'Elysée des principaux ministres
français et allemands ont signé le texte
du traité qui associe désormais France
et Allemagne sur le plan de la politique
étrangère de la défense de l'information
et de la culture mais derrière l'amitié
affichée les débuts des couples
franco-allemands ont souvent été
poussifs comme entre François Mitterrand
et elle mutecole la haine socialiste
l'autre conservateur alors pour arriver
à ce geste de Concorde qui a marqué
l'imaginaire collectif il a fallu
surmonter leur profonde divergence
politique c'est finalement le tournant
de la rigueur pris par Mitterrand en
1983 et l'engagement des deux hommes
pour l'Europe qui briseront la glace
entre Jacques Chirac et Gérard troorder
aussi début difficile ils ont deux
visions différentes de l'Europe alors
après quelques passes d'armes il décide
d'accorder leur violon rendez-vous
toutes les six semaines et grâce à cela
il travaille ensuite deux concerts en
2003 il s'oppose ensemble à la guerre en
Irak et invente les conseils des
ministres franco-allemand
couple fonctionnel malgré des
différences de style Nicolas Sarkozy et
Angela Merkel au point que l'on parlera
parfois de mercosi c'est dans la crise
que ce nous leur complicité à leur actif
la traversée de la crise financière de
2008 et la signature des accords de
Minsk sur la Crimée
par contraste les relations sont plus
froides avec François Hollande mais cela
ne dure qu'un temps
je crois qu'avec Madame Merkel sont les
événements les épreuves qui nous ont
rapprochés s'il n'y avait pas eu
la Grèce la zone euro et l'Ukraine et
terrorisme les réfugiés tellement de
sujets qui nous oblige à aller au-delà
des sensibilités des préventions des
différences sur ce qui était mon avis
accessoires pour aller vers l'essentiel
la crise toujours la crise pour Emmanuel
Macron c'était celle du covid le couple
franco-allemand s'engage dans un plan de
relance européen avec un endettement
commun des différents pays de l'Union
une avancée historique pour la frugal
Allemagne dont la rigueur budgétaire est
une vertue cardinale cette confiance
reste à confirmer avec le nouveau
chancelier Olaf Scholtz pour le moment
assez distant
ce couple Fabrice dalméda il dépend
vraiment aussi de la personnalité des
deux dirigeants ça joue mais après bon
il y a quand même une structure
1963 c'est là que de Gaulle et à 9h font
ce traité avant ça on a oublié Schuman
quand même
qui a été très important pour créer la
Communauté européenne du charbon et de
l'acier au début des années 50 puis pour
la création de la Communauté européenne
si je dis ça c'est parce qu'en fait on
s'aperçoit que depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale il y a une compréhension des
élites françaises et allemandes que si
on travaille pas ensemble le pire est
possible donc c'est pour ça que ce que
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure sur le
fait qu'il y a des traité de l'Elysée il
prévoit les échanges d'enfants des
colliers d'adolescents les jumelages
c'est crucial dans le traité et c'est ça
qu'on veut développer il prévoit bien
sûr la défense et il prévoit bien sûr
l'économie et c'est pour ça qu'on a des
problèmes parce qu'on est
complémentaires on a besoin de faire
cette paix entre nous et en même temps
on est concurrents l'Allemagne c'est
notre premier partenaire commercial mais
on importe plus qu'on exporte chez eux
donc depuis des années il y a cette
espèce de déficit commercial qui malgré
tout pèse en France on considère qu'une
partie de notre dette se retrouve dans
les bénéfices des entreprises allemandes
donc quand les Allemands nous disent
mais tenez votre dette on leur dit mais
attendez on l'a fait pour vous notre
dette donc qu'est-ce que vous pensez
donc c'est ça la difficulté c'est qu'il
y a à la fois du structurel et là-dessus
effectivement il y a des personnalités
mais il y a des personnalités face à
l'histoire parce que en réalité je
trader Chirac ce qui est ce qui reste
dans la mémoire c'est 2003 mais vu du
gouvernement allemand à l'époque qui est
le premier à dire qu'ils iront pas faire
la guerre en Irak les Allemands ont la
trouille en permanence que Chirac change
d'avis donc il passe leur temps à
envoyer des messages dans le cabinet à
l'époque de gars Schröder ils sont
inquiets ils se disent ils va lâcher
Jacques Chirac il lâche toujours ce
coup-là il va pas lâcher il va tenir
donc résultat on a cette image qui va
rester mais la même chose quand on
regarde call et Mitterrand il y a deux
personnalités différentes deux parties
politiques différentes à l'échelle
européenne et en même temps on se
souvient tous Comment au moment de
l'unification allemande la trouille des
Français que ce soit le retour de la
grande Allemagne et on est encore dans
cette trouille du retour de chacun pour
soi Léo clim qu'est-ce qui pourrait
faire l'objet d'un projet commun on
parle beaucoup de réindustrialisation de
protectionnisme en même temps les
Allemands ils sont pas encore
complètement là-dedans on a le sentiment
on sont dans un profond dilemme par
rapport à ça puisque c'est une nation
exportatrice qui vit de ces exportations
vers la France et vers d'autres pays
européens mais au-delà bien sûr donc
entrer dans une guerre commerciale avec
les États-Unis ça a un prix beaucoup
plus élevé pour les Allemands que pour
les Français donc c'est pas par hasard
que la France pousse plus en ce sens que
l'Allemagne
on parle des batteries électriques
notamment en groupe ou pourquoi pas des
grands groupes pourquoi pas aller sur
les puces les microprocesseurs on peut
l'imaginer on peut considérer que
Airbus et était un accident dans le
complément quoi non mais très très
sincèrement est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'exemples
de ce qu'on appelle en français des
champions industriels qui marchent bien
entre France et l'Allemagne en général
il y en a toujours un qui prend le
dessus c'est normal et chez Airbus ça a
été des psychodrames pendant des années
pour construire des avions pour la
jalousie autour de qui était pour vous
c'est seulement la petite musique
française de ce discours sur la
réindustrialisation avec des projets
communs français Allemagne c'est pas
partager autrement
si je pense que c'est ça peut être un
intérêt commun qu'on peut partager bien
sûr après on a moins ce sujet de la même
volonté politique peut-être le grand
problème de l'Allemagne en ce moment
c'est effectivement la guerre en Ukraine
en Ukraine l'Allemagne obnubilé bien sûr
par ça c'est beaucoup plus proche pour
elle et elle regarde elle a le regard
tourné vers l'Est moi ce que je reproche
aux dirigeants allemands c'est de penser
que le franco-allemand là-dessus est un
acquis que c'est donc c'est là que je
trouve que l'image du couple est
pertinente c'est à dire que non il faut
réinvestir pour le faire vivre parce que
les allemand non pas compris je dirais
en tout cas les élites politiques
allemandes aussi les élites économiques
et médiatiques que en dehors de leur
modèle de défense qui a été
délégué à aux États-Unis en dehors de
leur modèle économique largement
dépendant de la Chine il y a aussi la
base de tout c'est à dire l'Europe et
hausse et au cœur de l'Europe la
relation franco-allemande qui n'est pas
toujours acquise voilà alors je sais pas
si excusez-moi mais vous dites que la
coopération airbus est un accident mais
tout le monde se partage les emplois par
exemple je sais qui airbus est présent
naturellement à Toulouse mais également
à Munich donc on essaie de coopérer
chacun en profite et c'est ça le
bénéfice de la coopérative ça a été des
psychodes pour en arriver là
du
futuriste que tout a été un peu
déstabilisé donc en effet les fauteurs
de troupes sont les Allemands parce
qu'on faisait un truc à deux pour l'été
à trois et pareil pour le Cher aura une
métal est arrivé alors que voilà non ce
que disait Léo clim sur l'est parce que
là la Pologne elle a très très bien
comprise si on enlève le nucléaire la
Pologne va devenir la première armée en
Europe c'est quand même Paris ça veut
dire ça veut dire quand même une
nouvelle priorité Allemagne Pologne on
regarde plus à l'est que l'Allemagne la
Pologne et la France sont ont des
réunions régulières dans ce qu'on
appelle le Triangle de Weimar qui marche
mal en ce moment n'ont pas de la fosse
de la France et de l'Allemagne mais
plutôt du gouvernement polonais qui est
un petit peu nationaliste conservateur
et qui est moins européen
et beaucoup moins européen que qu'il ne
devrait l'être alors il se rachète
aujourd'hui avec l'Ukraine parce qu'on
est fait on voit bien qu'ils sont très
allant parce qu'il n'aime pas les Russes
et donc voilà mais elle livre
massivement
c'est qu'en effet l'amitié
franco-allemande elle est pas spontanée
on a des cultures différentes on a des
organisations et institutionnelles
complètement différentes nous sommes un
État centralisé c'est un État fédéral et
donc donc il y a en effet des
différences pour le dire simplement
le reportage le reportage manqué avec je
pense ce couple franco-allemand qui a
été le plus emblématique était Giscard
Schmitt parce qu'ils étaient opposés
politiquesment et en effet ils ont su
bâtir parce que ils ont su qu'il fallait
à chaque fois remettre le métier sur le
tapis discuter et la confiance la
confiance est essentielle ça a confiance
il y a quand même parce que là pas mal
de mauvaises manières faites par
l'Allemagne
il y a derrière une confiance européenne
qui suit s'il y a une difficulté
franco-allemande il y a pas de solution
européenne qui suit
la confiance ne peut pas être celui qui
amène quelque chose mais quand la France
et l'Allemagne s'entende tout va bien
quand elles le s'entendent pas c'est pas
très bon pour l'Europe oui Martin on est
d'accord sur ce point il n'en demeure
pas moins que on sembler que l'Allemagne
défend ses intérêts nationaux et ce fut
le cas également dans Gala Merkel malgré
tout son courage tout elle a quand même
gouverné en saisant ce pays et on arrive
à un stade de la relation
franco-allemande qui est un âge adulte
c'est à dire que c'est un pays c'est une
forte démocratie depuis 1949 c'est un
pays industriel majeur et que c'est
normal que il défendent son point de vue
mais je vous rejoins tout à fait pour
dire que lorsqu'il y a une crise au
niveau européen on ne peut pas faire
autrement que de s'adapter sur la force
et la faiblesse il est vrai que lorsque
vous allez aux États-Unis au Japon ou
ailleurs on voit des beaucoup de
voitures allemandes on voit nettement
moins de voitures françaises et quand on
comprend ça en voyageant un peu dans les
autres pôles du monde on comprend que
les Allemands sont très très forts sur
le plan industriel et que c'est
peut-être aussi notre faiblesse
vous avez un avion à nous montrer je
crois
fier d'Airbus en tant qu'Européen et là
vous me racontez que c'était un chemin
de croix finalement c'est pour ça que je
l'ai fait un accident
c'est une chose positive alors
absolument airbus est une belle réussite
bien sûr mais c'est mais dans la douleur
mais tellement et ça revient aussi
régulièrement c'est plus apaisé
aujourd'hui mais je voudrais dire que si
on comprend la relation franco-allemande
que il y a des gens qui pètent pour ça
comme une relation
un alignement d'intérêt
à ce moment-là je pense que ça que ça ne
va pas il faut qu'il y ait c'est ça mon
plaidoyer plus que juste l'intérêt
conjoint il faut avoir conscience un
trésor commun qui est l'Europe et mais
que c'est
important
laissez-moi juste terminer là-dessus
parce que la chose cruciale de ce
dimanche pour moi c'est que la France
est la manne soit capable de retrouver
de montrer qu'elles sont capables de
retrouver le crédit et le leadership
qu'elles ont perdu au sein bien sûr de
l'Europe et vis-à-vis des autres pays
ça c'est très important ce qui est dit
là est-ce qu'il jamais eu et la France
et l'Allemagne une forme d'aveuglement
de ce qui était en train de se jouer ou
en tout cas de retard à l'allumage dans
la nécessaire aide militaire à donner et
fortement à l'Ukraine c'est à dire que
avant de répondre à votre question je
voulais vous dire quand même dire vous
dites il y a non mais je vais répondre à
la question non non vous avez dit
c'est pas très trésor un trésor d'accord
mais moi je suis très inquiet parce que
l'enseignement de la langue en Allemand
en France est en train de baisser
fortement moi je fais l'allemand voilà
et le français en Allemagne et donc
pourquoi y a-t-il un tel des intérêts
pourquoi a-t-on des règles difficultés
de trouver des professeurs d'allemand en
France c'est un vrai une vraie question
d'interrogations alors ensuite pour
répondre à votre question oui le retour
de la guerre de retour même nous donner
qu'il a eu une un projet comme partout
s'agissant de la France et de
l'Allemagne rappelez-vous des propos
d'Emmanuel Macron comme quoi il fallait
ménager ne pas humilier la Russie de la
démo Poutine en Ukraine ça n'est pas
passé du tout et quand on voit
aujourd'hui aussi les hésitations du
chancelier ola scholls quant à la la
maison des chars léopards on a toujours
pas compris en Ukraine donc nous avons
eu effectivement tous les deux un retard
à l'allumage qui peut expliquer qui est
un sentiment de malaise aujourd'hui
non mais juste c'est pour dire un truc
positif sur les amitiés franco-allemand
c'est que l'exemple de De Gaulle et de
Adenauer que qui était sympa à dessiner
mais il était un peu fripé mais j'aimais
bien dessiner
j'ai fait c'est important parce que j'ai
voulu faire au dessus des lysée
puisqu'on va parler du traité l'Élysée
un drapeau qui serait une sorte de
colombe et avec le drapeau français et
drapeau allemand et peut-être que
dimanche on pourra peut-être amener à
imaginer que un jour pas avec Poutine
mais avec un Russe et un Ukrainien on
pourra imaginer peut-être une amitié qui
sera le un nouveau traité de l'Elysée
ça se terminera comme ça heureusement
mais le dessin il est intéressant parce
qu'en fait si par rapport à votre
question si on repart du traité
franco-allemande 63 c'est parce que les
deux pays se situent dans une stratégie
par rapport à un même adversaire et avec
un même allié l'adversaire c'est la
Russie soviétique l'Allier c'est
l'Allier américain et de Gaulle et
Adenauer navigue dans cette situation
aujourd'hui le paradoxe c'est qu'on a un
ennemi qui est la Russie qui s'est
manifesté à nos portes mais qu'on n'a
pas la même réaction par rapport à notre
allié comment vous l'expliquez pour les
Allemands l'essentiel c'est collé à
l'Allier c'est collé aux États-Unis pour
les Français il faut qu'on ait une
troisième stratégie une autre voie
stratégique qui permette effectivement
de construire une autonomie stratégique
européenne
en collaboration mais en autonomie par
rapport à l'OTAN alors pour les
Allemands c'est inaudible et c'est
inaudible aussi pour l'autre
protagoniste parce que c'est la question
c'est où est l'Europe aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui l'Europe il y en a une
partie non non je vais finir Pascal
merci il y en a une autre il y a un
endroit qui est essentiel qui est
Varsovie aujourd'hui le cœur de l'Europe
militaire c'est la Pologne il faut avoir
conscience de ça c'est la Pologne c'est
là qu'on masse nos armes donc est-ce que
c'est de ce côté là qu'on doit décider
et eux ils sont totalement alignés sur
les États-Unis il pense qu'il y a pas
d'autonomie stratégique européenne donc
les Français on a on a un petit défaut
de conception c'est à dire qu'on reste
sur ce que de Gaulle avec vanille
qu'aujourd'hui sur la caisse la question
stratégique militaire
et on est persuadé d'avoir raison alors
que peut-être nous n'avons pas raison
alors là
puisqu'on parlait de l'Élysée
sur l'indépendant des États-Unis le
général de Gaulle était beaucoup plus
indépendant que nous le sommes
aujourd'hui puisque nous avons après 62
ans
que vous dites non non ce que vous dites
c'est la légende goienne en 63 nous
sommes dans le commandement militaire
intégré de l'OTAN en 63 on arrive après
Cuba ou de Gaulle a appelé Kennedy pour
lui dire quoi qu'il se passe la France
sera aux côtés des États-Unis quoi qu'il
se passe
c'était quand même pas très facile pour
lui de voilà bon en tout cas ce qui est
simple aujourd'hui c'est vrai c'est nos
amis polonais sont parce que tout
transit par là tout transite par là mais
ce qu'il faut pas oublier c'est qu'on a
aujourd'hui une administration
américaine qui est plutôt bienveillante
on a connu il y a pas très longtemps une
administration américaine qui était
beaucoup moins
sympathique avec l'Europe et qu'on est
pas sûr que l'année prochaine puisqu'il
y aura des élections aux États-Unis
l'année prochaine que il y aura une
majorité qui soit de nouveau à lente
avec l'Europe là ça tombe bien mais nos
amis Vars polonais il faut aussi qu'il
se rende compte il y avait des élections
cette année aussi en Pologne
de soutien à l'Ukraine aussi
quel sera le titulaire enfin le celui
qui remportera l'élection
essayons de nous projeter sur ce qui
peut se passer dimanche stratégique
américain c'est on est on n'est pas dans
dans des choses qui sont périphériques
là on est dans le coeur stratégique
intéressant
d'essayer de travailler avec eux et
d'aussi comprendre que peut-être sur le
sur le le volet missile par exemple
défense défense des missiles européens
peut-être qu'il faut s'aligner sur les
Allemands et les Américains et prendre
une solution israélienne on est on peut
pas vous l'avenir de la défense
européenne c'est le temps point à la
ligne non mais il faut sur certains
plans on n'a pas le choix de précision
excusez-moi rappelez-vous le la
rectification du traité franco-allemand
de l'Elysée avec coopération le
bundeslak le parlement allemand avait
rajouté après en bulle pour dire qu'on
restait très lié et solidaire des
États-Unis d'Amérique et cela n'avait
pas plus du tout au général de Gaulle
c'est pour ça que voilà
c'est très intéressant parce que on sort
voilà c'est pour ça je vais beaucoup
dans les écoles et je vais dans les
écoles dans les lycées pour parler du
traité de l'Élysée pour parler des
amitiés franco-allemandes
faut tout réapprendre à sortir des
clichés est-ce que vous dites sur la
Pologne ça fait quand même 20 ans qu'on
dit des clichés sur la Pologne
c'est quoi c'est on dit qu'ils sont
bourrés que c'est des plombiers que
c'est et là avec l'Ukraine où ils
accueille des Ukrainiens on dit ah oui
finalement la Pologne ils sont peut-être
un peu antisémites mais c'est pas mal
finalement attends je me dis mais
attends il faut sortir de tous les
clichés et moi je suis un homme de
cliché caricaturiste je suis
caricaturiste dans un monde de clichés
piqué par les médias dire que moi je
suis en train de faire des caricatures
ou tu fais un peu du portrait des fois
de temps en temps dans un monde de
caricatures c'est incroyable et on va
enfin sortir les Polonais de clichés ils
méritent mieux alors
sur l'Allemagne et sur la Pologne qui
vont changer un petit peu les choses et
le notre intérêt aujourd'hui c'est que
schols Macron puisqu'ils ont été élus en
octobre 2021 et en juin 2022 sprelle la
responsabilité qu'il est l'heure pour
ressouder alors je sais pas quel est le
projet sur lequel il tomberont d'accord
mais il y a toujours un petit pas à
faire un petit pas va entraîner quelque
chose et c'est leur responsabilité de 2
minutes à peine je voudrais qu'on
s'arrête un instant sur
Léo clim il est soutenu il est soutenu
dans cette politique énergétique
on va dire cavalier seul par rapport à
l'Europe il est soutenu sur la question
commerciale il est soutenu par sa
coalition vraiment ou pas alors il a un
problème bien sûr c'est un problème de
composer avec deux partenaires plus son
propre parti c'est une recherche
d'équilibre en permanence et d'ailleurs
il y a quelqu'un à l'Élysée qui a eu un
bon mot récemment qui a dit on a parfois
l'impression d'être le quatrième
partenaire de coalition cette affaire
c'est à dire que c'est tellement tout le
temps cette recherche déséquilibre
on peut dire que la chouette n'a pas
passé une très bonne première année en
poste après bien sûr avec des
difficultés majeures tout effectivement
beaucoup de certitudes allemandes
complètement chamboulées on peut dire
que son ministre de l'économie qui est
un écologiste en l'occurrence a bien
fait le boulot pour remplacer par
exemple intégralement le gaz russe par
d'autres sources donc
l'Allemagne a fait montre aussi à la
fois d'une capacité assez grande
réaction voilà sur sur ensuite ce qui
concerne
la Réunion dimanche alors justement pour
terminer là-dessus à quoi on peut
s'attendre il y aura du symbole c'est
indéniable et c'est important mais
au-delà
il faut que ce soit le point de départ
d'analyser un alignement stratégique et
sur les questions de défense c'est
crucial parce que kify effectivement
s'appuyer sur un allié américain c'est
vrai mais en même temps il y a un
travail à fournir faut penser à une
chose j'ai juste un petit rappel pendant
la guerre froide en fait il y avait en
franc en Allemagne une un corps
expéditionnaire français une force
d'occupation qui était là et qui est
montée jusqu'à 250 000 hommes pourquoi
elle était là l'idée c'est que si jamais
il y avait une attaque nucléaire ces
hommes là seraient vitrifiés il serait
supprimé et ça poussait la à ce moment
là avoir une réaction nucléaire donc ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que la
France et l'Allemagne était solidaire
face à une éventuelle attaque massive de
l'Union soviétique il faut retrouver ce
sens de solidarité là c'est crucial
merci on va s'arrêter là on va s'arrêter
là mais voilà quelque chose me dit qu'on
en reparlera beaucoup sur sur ce plateau
en tout cas on suivra c'est
commémorations ce dimanche merci
beaucoup d'être venu débattre
aujourd'hui vous restez avec moi plan
cul dans une dizaine de minutes nos
affranchis pour leur partie prix mais
d'abord on va parler un petit peu de vos
dessins les voiles les affranchis allez
on va les voir en coulisses il se
prépare Bertrand Périer ce soir qui va
revenir sur la dernière provoque de
Cyril Hanouna le mot de la semaine de
Mariette d'arrigan c'est le mot
résignation on verra pourquoi et puis
les archives de Brandon warrête sur le
congrès du PS à tout à l'heure les amis
je le disais on va plonger dans dans
votre rétrospective de l'année le tout
en dessin et puis en portrait avec elle
d'amour
[Musique]
si on vous invite Plantu c'est parce que
cela fait 50 ans que vous croquez le
monde qui nous entoure et c'est peut
dire que ces derniers temps
l'inspiration ne vous a pas manqué j'en
Planus vous êtes dessinateur de presse
caricaturiste fondateur de Cartooning
for piece en ce moment vous publiez
Salton pour la planète recueille de vos
dessins de 2022 un hors-série du monde
revient sur vos 50 ans de collaboration
plus un livre hommage à Hergé sont
Tintin plontues vous ne vous arrêtez
jamais alors que retenons-nous de votre
année 2022 votre regard parfois acerbe
mais toujours juste sur la politique
française votre combat pour la paix il y
a 50 ans votre colombe vous la dessinez
contre la guerre du Vietnam aujourd'hui
elle se pose en Ukraine
vous vous intéressez aussi à notre
planète qui brûle
mais ce qui restera comme le combat de
votre vie Plantu c'est bien celui pour
la liberté d'expression la liberté de
tout dire et de tout dessiner je pense
que tous les artistes
ont beaucoup beaucoup de droits et ils
ont tous les droits de s'exprimer et de
raconter ce qu'ils ont envie de faire
partager une fois que j'ai dit ça c'est
pas suffisant il faut aussi savoir que
quand on s'exprime il peut y avoir
derrière la porte ou au coin de la rue
des gens qui ne comprennent rien aux
images et donc on a un travail
pédagogique national européen
international à faire vous vous servez
de vos crayons pour illustrer dénoncer
réfléchir moquer alors plontue vous qui
dites ne savoir pas faire autre chose
que dessiner nous avons une question ce
soir comment
pour dessiner une actualité si tragique
c'est vrai qu'elle est elle est
plombante cette année 2022 dont on sort
plombantes moi je sais de faire du
comment j'essaie de faire du bien là où
ça fait mal voilà c'est
[Musique]
mettre le doigt là où ça fait mal mais
il y a jamais de méchanceté dans vos
dessins ni même de cruauté parfois des
fois il y a des hommes politiques que je
croise
pas dû faire plaisir mais ça fait partie
mais ils savent que je me lève pas le
matin en me disant je veux
dézinguer ou faire de la peine pour le
plaisir c'est parce que je suis porté
par une idée éditoriale et puis après
vague le dessin il s'en va comme ça et
puis après il me revient ah oui là et
même au moment où je fais mon dessin je
le comprends mieux presque deux semaines
après en voyant la réaction des uns et
des autres donc il a une vie après même
pour vous qu'est-ce qui vous nourrit
aujourd'hui le plus parce que 50 ans au
monde on sait que vous étiez très proche
de la rédaction des journalistes
aujourd'hui vous êtes
toujours des journalistes
mais parce que j'ai besoin de de ce
regard avec les rédacteurs en chef qui
m'ont accompagné pendant des années en
me disant oui oui ça c'est bien et c'est
de d'amplifier telle chose soit si tu
peux te calmer de ce côté-là voilà et à
la fois des fois ils avaient tort et des
fois ils avaient raison et c'est des
fois je râle un peu et puis je me dis
mais non finalement quand il y a cette
rédacteur en chef qui vous disent essaie
de plutôt de dans cette orientation là
on se dit bon bah c'est que et souvent
ils avaient raison et je suis moi qui
raté mes études je suis baigné par le
regard de ces rédacteurs en chef qui
vont plus loin vous êtes très très
grande dessinateur un grand artiste vous
répétez sans cesse que vous avez raté
vos études vous allez dans les écoles
d'ailleurs après une année pareille
qu'est-ce que vous leur dites aux jeunes
d'écouter les autres par exemple j'étais
à trappe il y a pas longtemps il y a une
école qui s'appelle le collège Henri
Wallon les
les enseignantes enseignent l'empathie
c'est génial il y a l'algèbre le
français peut-être l'allemand je sais
pas l'histoire les géographie et
l'empathie mais c'est génial essayez
aujourd'hui
dans cette classe là ils sont ces petits
amours ils sont quand même heureux
en tout cas il je suis sûr que c'est
quand en faisant des ponts et en faisant
des voyages alors grâce au monde et
grâce beaucoup au Quai d'Orsay qui m'a
fait connaître tous les dessinateurs de
la planète et comme kofiana le
secrétaire général de l'ONU m'a dit de
rassembler des dessinateurs chrétiens
juifs musulmans moi je les connais tous
donc c'était facile pour moi et c'est
grâce à l'image du monde et c'est grâce
aux ambassadeurs conseillers culturels
institut français Alliance française que
j'ai pu faire des rencontres dans le
monde entier avec des dessinateurs des
chrétiens des juifs et des musulmans
alors on va plonger dans le livre on va
d'abord plonger dans l'actualité j'ai vu
sur votre compte Instagram que il y
avait encore un dessin par jour minimum
des retraites
vous avez pas l'impression d'une
histoire sans fin quand même là si
d'autant plus que j'ai je me souviens
des grèves de 95 je les ai encore en
tête et c'était pas les mêmes
protagonistes mais c'était les mêmes
blocages et moi je trouve que c'est pas
moi je suis passionné par la vie
politique là où on était en train de
parler du franco-allemand j'apprends à
chaque fois sur la Pologne sur Airbus
sur l'Allemagne mais c'est génial et à
chaque fois qu'on me que j'apprends
quelque chose je sors mon feutre et je
dessine presque sur les tables j'exagère
que vous l'avez dans la poche le feutre
depuis l'enfance au début j'avais des
crayons de couleur
parce que je parlais pas mes parents
étaient inquiets d'ailleurs ils parlent
pas mais d'ailleurs mes premiers pas
c'est drôle mon père m'a donné un crayon
et j'ai fait mes croyants que je
m'accrochais à quelque chose j'ai
commencé à faire mes premiers pas
exactement et j'ai pu comme ça
m'exprimer moi qui était très timide
incroyable j'étais maladement timide au
moins je pouvais faire des dessins et
partager une émotion voilà un autre
dessin c'est l'actualité alors le Parti
socialiste s'est trouvé un chef selon sa
direction Olivier Faure mais vous vous
l'avez mis déjà dans un corbillard
direction quoi direction une sorte de
château insoumis à Château Kremlin
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant
un petit Mélenchon qui est
exactement exactement et puis
c'est les idées sociales moi j'ai
toujours voté PS ou voilà
toujours à gauche mais plutôt PS et là
voilà je vois que
ils sont en train de de se transformer
dans des petits c'est eux qui sont
soumis c'est le PS qui est soumis alors
justement le chef des insoumis c'est
intéressant de le revoir il y a
d'ailleurs toute la bande des des des
insoumis national on va voir
alors là il y en a une trop parce que là
il y en a un qui a disparu des radars
c'est le pauvre katmas Adrien
je sais mais il serait pas au milieu du
dessin Israël dans la page d'à côté
ouais ça je l'ai mis ça dans le bouquin
et puis c'est vrai qu'ils sont alors ils
sont sympas à dessiner et puis Mélenchon
quand même vous lui avez fait une tête
moins sur ce dessin que le précédent
mais on n'est pas loin mais quoi c'est
c'est pas loin d'entre Staline et chez
giping il y a quelque chose de d'un peu
de dictateur dans la manière dont vous
le croquez alors c'est intéressant ce
que vous dites parce que quand j'ai mon
idée je griffonne et quand je fais mon
dessin sur le papier mon doigt la page
de papier me dise autre chose et à la
fin ça devient un dessin qui échappe un
peu à ce que j'avais au départ mais à la
fin bah si ça ressemble à telle ou tel
c'est comme ça
la présidentielle elle est au cœur de ce
livre on va voir un autre dessin cette
fois-ci c'est Manuel Macron qui porte
marraine Le Pen sur le dos ça c'est
l'Assemblée nationale pardonnez-moi
paralysie totale avec un Emmanuel Macron
qui voilà est obligé de
peine de Penne
et le pyjama qui avait Macron dans le
dessin d'avant là c'est le pyjama de mon
père
ça c'est le moment le pyjama qui m'a
toujours c'est le pyjama plus le
quadrillé de la robe de chambre donc
l'Assemblée en déambulateur va-t-elle
réussir à tenir le président et si on
regarde la campagne là on voit parce que
le président avec Marine Le Pen
exactement c'est nourri de marine au
deuxième tour et c'est nourri de Marine
Le Pen puisque c'est grâce à elle par un
refus des Français qu'il a été élu et
maintenant
on se retrouve avec les républicains qui
vont finalement aider le président à
faire passer ses lois et alors donc
emporté par l'élan j'ai dessiné une
petite
Elisabeth borne en elle me fait penser à
vous savez le petit chien qui dit uno
what Happy et Droopy c'est une sorte de
Droopy mais qui fait semblant d'être
happy je suis pas sûr que ce soit à pied
tous les jours en effet avec ce qu'elle
doit porter sur sur les bras l'Ukraine
évidemment on va voir quelques quelques
dessins ça fait 50 ans que vous dessinez
à peu près pour le monde exactement j'ai
commencé par la guerre du Vietnam et
voyez là c'est la guerre en Ukraine
comment vous avez vécu ce retour de la
guerre comme vous alors là vraiment je
suis un citoyen basique avec ça en plus
ici la seule différence je dis je
ressens la même chose que vous on voit
ces gens qui partent on voit alors je
les dessine je regarde la télévision je
regarde des photos et puis je les
dessine je fais les petites ukrainiennes
je fais les enfants je fais les valises
je fais bon et puis après on y rajoute
la couleur bleu de drapeau la couleur
jaune du drapeau et puis voilà c'est
juste une manière de dire on pense à
vous on est avec vous c'est un dessin
c'est que ça c'est un partage d'émotion
et puis et puis ça voilà c'est ça nous
permet de de
participer au combat à notre manière en
tant que artiste en tant que citoyen
pour leur dire vous n'êtes pas seul il y
en a un autre qui est plus politique
encore c'est celui-là oui alors d'abord
elles sont belles les Ukrainiennes et
donc évidemment je fais et puis c'est
vrai que c'est quand même assez beau
l'autre crétin là qui est en train
d'envahir l'Ukraine il est sur la sur la
gauche on se ressemble tellement alors
c'est intéressant de traiter la
ressemblance parce que les ukrainiens et
les Russes sont toujours été très
proches en réalité même si en ce moment
ils sont en train de subir la guerre
mais à la fois quand même un jour ça se
terminera comme je disais tout à l'heure
évidemment ils vont se remettre autour
de mais évidemment
mais évidemment ils vont se retrouver
autour d'une table j'espère que l'autre
sera en tôle
et c'est comme ça que ça va se
il faut être patient et se dire on va
les aider et on va ne jamais oublier
leur souffrance comme on est en train
d'oublier je vous le dis en passant la
souffrance des Palestiniens je moi je
travaille beaucoup avec des Palestiniens
et des Israéliens je n'oublie pas il
faut jamais faut toujours penser à
l'humiliation quand il y a une
humiliation faut toujours se dire ça va
nous péter à la gueule quand les gens
sont humiliés il faut et moi je suis
toujours du côté des gens qui sont
humiliés et des fois il s'expriment de
manière exagérée mais faut toujours se
rappeler ils sont humiliés donc il faut
les écouter les signatures de plantule
elles sont un peu pixelisées c'est la
colombe avec le rameau d'olivier et
c'est la souris vous êtes la souris et
vous êtes mais vous êtes la souris je me
suis rendu compte que les lecteurs
c'était approprié mes souris et c'est ça
me plaît comme ça merci beaucoup Plantu
voici donc l'année de Plantu 2022 sale
temps pour la planète calmane Lévy
graphique il y a beaucoup de choses
aussi vos 50 ans de dessin c'est un
hors-série dans le journal Le Monde et
puis Tintin c'est votre relation atteint
et mon amour c'est mon amour d'Hergé et
c'est l'aventure que j'ai raconté entre
mon amour d'Hergé et les impressions
j'ai dessiné énormément de dessins qui
font que ma manière de dessiner est
certainement j'aimerais avoir le talent
de Hergé mais en tout cas j'ai été à un
élève
discret de d'Hergé que j'ai adoré et je
suis allé dans une école en Belgique
cette modestie et ce et ce respect que
vous avez c'est aussi votre marque de
fabrique plein de tu vous restez avec
moi c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris je suis
sûr qu'ils vont vous faire réagir on les
accueille tout de suite
bonjour installez-vous
Brandon warrett et ses archives Mariette
darrigan et son mot de la semaine et
Bertrand Perrier pour sa carte blanche
je crois que vous êtes assez commode
agacé par la nouvelle provocation de
Cyril Hanouna on va voir ça dans un tout
petit instant bienvenue à vous les
affranchis on commence avec vous Brandon
on en parlait Olivier Faure et donc
officiellement réélu premier secrétaire
avec
50,83% des voix face aux maires de Rouen
en Nicolas Mayer Rossignol au terme
d'une nuit de contestation de toute
violence de toutes parts et voilà qui
ravive donc les pires souvenirs du Parti
socialiste mais oui souvenez-vous de
2008 avec cette finale 100% féminine
entre Ségolène Royal et Martino BRI les
résultats du second tour qui plongent le
parti dans l'affrontement accusation de
tricherie demande d'un nouveau vote les
deux camps se crèvent le chignon jusqu'à
l'intervention d'une commission qui
après maintes vérification donne la
victoire à Martine Aubry avec 100 de
voies d'avance Martine Aubry devient la
première femme élue au poste de premier
secrétaire aucun socialiste ne doit
manquer aux Français aucun et je l'ai
dit à Ségolène dans les équipes que nous
constituerons ses amis en toute leur
place nous ferons en sorte d'être une
force de transformation à l'intérieur du
parti socialiste pour que nous puissions
écrire ensemble une nouvelle page de
notre histoire commune
vous remarquerez que Ségolène Royal n'a
pas de mots pour Martine Aubry
absolument ça m'étonne pas
du tout là la cohésion de la famille
politique puisque ni Martine Aubry ni
Ségolène Royal ne parviendront à
représenter 4 ans plus tard le Parti
socialiste à l'élection présidentielle
de 2012 alors en revanche quand François
Mitterrand a été élu à la tête du parti
en 1971 Épinay n'a aucune contestation
effectivement congrès d'Épinay François
Mitterrand savait qu'avec sa petite
liste il avait aucune chance dans
l'emporter face au tandem sortant Alain
Savary et guimolé alors enfin stratège
politique l'élu charentais de la Nièvre
tente le tout pour le tout objectif
rassembler
celui qui n'accepte pas la rupture
la méthode ça passe ensuite
celui qui ne consomme pas à la rupture
politique ça va le soir c'est secondaire
avec la société capitaliste celui-là je
le dis il ne peut pas être adhérent du
parti socialiste
adhérents du parti socialiste François
Mitterrand a été seulement 5 jours avant
ce discours donc imaginez quand même
mais ça n'empêche pas pour autant de
rallier à sa cause les listes de Gaston
de fer Pierre Mauroy et Jean-Pierre
Chevènement le gentleman cambrioleur de
la politique et nouveau leader
incontesté s'empare du Parti socialiste
pour seulement 2000 voix avant de
s'emparer 10 ans plus tard de l'Élysée
alors 1997 pour terminer cette fois bien
le scénario était écrit d'avance la
nomination de Lionel Jospin comme
premier ministre après la victoire de la
gauche aux élections législatives
déclenchent une nouvelle élection au
sein du Parti socialiste deux candidats
s'affrontent Jean-Luc Mélenchon le
sénateur de l'Essonne et François
Hollande ne député de la Corrèze
grandissime favoris alors au congrès de
Brest pour déjouer les pronostics le
Petit Poucet ce qu'on appelle à son père
spirituel je m'en tiens à la leçon que
m'a donnée peu de temps avant qu'il
disparaisse lui dont j'avoue avec fierté
qu'il était un maître à penser pour moi
le président Mitterrand il me dit
le président Mitterrand
ne s'est jamais
je marche monsieur
Jean-Luc Mélenchon avait sans doute un
peu trop en tête les images d'épinées
comme image d'Épinal il n'y aura pas de
tonnerre de Brest François Hollande
humilie sévèrement Jean-Luc Mélenchon
avec 91% des voix et succèdent sans
surprise à Lionel Jospin comme premier
secrétaire du Parti socialiste
d'Épinal pour Mélenchon c'est très
intéressant il était caricaturiste dans
les années 70 oui oui il faisait des
dessins qui étaient pas mal d'ailleurs
mais et moi j'aimais bien ces dessins
j'étais pas connu mais je les ai vu
après
est-ce qu'il vous manque le Parti
socialiste quand il était dans toute sa
puissance et sa force la réponse est oui
et oui un amour de gauche mais oui je me
souviens que quand Mitterrand a été élu
j'étais à la Bastille et moi ça me
s'était mourrait je rêvais que
Mitterrand me demande d'adhérer aux
parties socialiste il a jamais fait et
je suis jamais allé au PS d'ailleurs
quand on voit vos destin ou alors c'est
ce que vous redoutez mais en tout cas
quand il était malade j'ai fait exprès
de faire un président gaillard je le
critiquais dans les dessins mais je le
faisais jamais malade voilà ça fait
partie de ma manière de travailler allez
le mot de la semaine que vous avez
choisi Mariette à présent c'est le mot
résignation fruit d'un télescopage entre
l'actualité française des retraites et
l'actualité internationale explique-nous
ça voilà il y a parfois dans
l'atmosphère médiatique comme dans
l'atmosphère climatique des télescopes
alors c'est exactement comme dans un
dessin merveilleux de Plantu il y a
toujours deux choses qui s'encastrer
voilà donc de l'actualité française
puisque la résignation a été ça m'a
vraiment paru curieux quand on les
syndicats préparaient le fameux Jeudi
Noir d'hier se demander si les gens les
Français allaient être mobilisés ou
résignés c'est un drôle de mots quand
même qui était déjà là dans notre
atmosphère d'ailleurs c'est un mot qui a
été consacré par une expression en
anglais de Big nation voilà the big
nation en anglais donc c'est pour ça que
le mot résigné était déjà là si on veut
bah c'est un phénomène qui a été très
bien comment dire observer aux
États-Unis dans le monde poste covid
c'est-à-dire les gens quittent leur
boulot quittent les grandes villes et
puis ils vont faire autre chose à
nouveau nouvelle vie commence on en a
aussi la résonance en France dans une
moindre mesure un ingénieur qui quitte
la grosse boîte pour aller faire une
startup ou bien bon voilà donc c'est ça
le sens positif de la résignation
Myriam vous vous avez très bien prononcé
en anglais mais en fait c'est du latin
c'est tenté c'est dû là ça vient d'où
alors en latin c'est revenir au signe
c'est-à-dire à la signature c'est à dire
au cachet de cirque on va mettre dans
une enveloppe qui contient les termes
d'un accord alors là je vais parler sous
le contrôle de verre trempé parce que le
terme est juridique au départ c'était
vraiment juridique on se met qu'on
revient sur un contrat exacte voilà la
résignation c'est le retour volontaire à
un contrat dont on peut changer les
termes donc c'est là-dessus que je
voulais insister parce que c'est
aujourd'hui en français le sens n'est
plus juridique il est psychologique dans
la et c'est une émotion plutôt négative
les gens sont résignés ils vont être
passifs ils vont accepter mais en fait
c'est beaucoup plus positif que ça et
intéressant voilà et donc cerise sur le
gâteau sémiologique pour moi cette
semaine c'est que non seulement il y
avait ce phénomène américain puis ici
nos grèves mais aussi vous savez la
yassineda Harden la première ministre
des hautes-élandaises qui a fait sa
propre résine raisin nation voilà parce
que cette femme est au fait de la gloire
elle a été très innovante dans son pays
etc le gouverne et elle a les
d'elle-même exactement j'ai plus
l'énergie à tel dit pour pour voilà donc
elle a dit ça demande tellement
d'énergie etc donc je fais ma
résignation c'est à dire quelle
volontairement elle est le contraire
d'une femme résignée volontairement elle
veut avoir une autre vie alors c'est un
peu de la com c'est à dire qu'elle a eu
une petite fille un bébé quand elle
était en poste et donc elle dit bah
maintenant elle va rentrer à l'école ma
fille il faut que j'aille la chercher
bon c'est de la com mais c'est quand
même très intéressant pour reboucler
pour finir sur notre sujet à nous les
français sont-ils résignés et passifs où
sont-ils au contraire dans une
résignation positive ça va être très
intéressant dans les semaines à venir et
moi j'aurais tendance à penser qu'en
tout cas en quelque sorte il ne resigne
pas le même contrat qu'en 95 ils vont
peut-être leur résignation la moduler un
coup oui pour la manif et un coup non
pour ne pas obéir à personne
c'est-à-dire ni au gouvernant rester
libre ni aux syndicats pour rester libre
car le mot contient cette once de
liberté qui est formidable ça vous
inspire la positive mais je trouve ça
émouvant parce que quand vous parlez de
cette manière d'accepter on va on va
être résigné et de faire ce contrat
c'est une énorme volonté un énorme
courage qu'il faudra des deux côtés et
cette première ministre néo-zélandaise
elle est extraordinaire parce que à la
fois les résignée elle va revenir chez
elle mais il faut un courage que les
hommes n'ont pas forcément toujours et
c'est pour ça que faut toujours
respecter le geste d'une femme qui a le
courage que beaucoup d'hommes n'ont pas
forcément on va terminer avec Maître
Bertrand Perrier et sont réquisitoire on
peut utiliser le terme ce soir
réquisitoire contre
l'extraordinaire diatribe de Cyril
Hanouna lundi dernier sur son plateau
sur ses 8 contre France Télévisions et
tout l'audiovisuel public oui c'est
réquisitoire il y a eu c'est bien celui
de Cyril Hanouna tout de blanc vêtus
comme une sorte de grand prêtre du petit
écran et qui dénonce les contributions
étatique à l'audiovisuel public 3
milliards 800 millions le chiffre est
exact mais si explique que ce montant
devrait être utilisé plutôt pour acheter
des voitures de police financer des
hôpitaux et des professeurs plutôt que
d'être financé à un service public qui
est dit-il ne fait rien n'est personne
et ne fait que critiquer et il finit par
un violent privatisément tout ça et tout
ça s'inscrit dans un contexte pour
l'animateur oui évidemment parce que en
réalité la veille de l'émission de Rima
Abdul Malak la ministre de la Culture a
fait un entretien dans le monde où elle
dénonce le chaos informationnel et elle
dit qu'il faudrait pour contrebalancer
cela responsabiliser les présentateurs
il n'y a pas besoin d'être grand clair
pour voir que Cyril Luna est dans le
viseur mais sur le fond qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez de ces propos là sur le
fond on peut pas échapper au constat
qu'il y a une sorte d'injustice voire
d'ingratitude de Cyril Hanouna qui a
commencé sur le service public
n'oublions pas que ces France 4 en 2010
qui a accueilli pour la première fois
Touche pas à mon poste donc il y a quand
même une forme de culot de la part de
Cyril Hanouna et puis il y a aussi
quelque chose d'un peu malhonnête dans
l'argumentation puisque il dit on
devrait financer plutôt la police que
l'audiovisuel c'est ce qu'on appelle en
rhétorique un faux dilemme on peut et on
doit financer les deux et puis et
évidemment on sait la démagogie l'excès
l'outran ce qui est un peu la marque de
fabrique de cire le nœud donc moi je
veux quand même répéter que le service
public informe éduque investige en quête
partage créé finance la création finance
les documentaires je pense récemment aux
documentaire de France 2 sur l'affaire
d'Outreau qui a un très beau
documentaire
sa place ailleurs que sur le service
public et puis le service public
contrairement à ce que dit si regardez
donna aide il aide via le Téléthon il
aide via le Sidaction et il y a aussi du
divertissement mais de qualité et c'est
d'ailleurs assez paradoxal parce que
beaucoup d'émissions de investissements
du service public sont produits par
Banijay société dont Cyril Hanouna est
actionnaire donc il ne peut pas
l'ignorer non plus une partie de jeu de
rôle et puis il y a voilà des émissions
phares qui ont redoré l'audience de
France Télévisions et du service public
je pense à c'est à vous qui est
d'ailleurs et on peut pas s'empêcher de
le noter le concurrent direct de Cyril
Hanouna et souvent c'est c'est à vous
qui fait de meilleures audiences alors
pour autant et pour terminer ce qu'il y
a pas matière à réflexion quand même à
travers les propos de Cyril
sur cette question du du du service
public audiovisuel parce que au-delà des
des outrances il faudrait pas que ça
fasse disparaître la nécessité d'une
vraie réflexion sur l'avenir de
l'audiovisuel français d'ailleurs il y a
actuellement une mission d'information
ici à l'Assemblée nationale qui a été
lancé et qui est présidé par un député
LR Jean-Jacques goldier et donc cette
question là doit être posée c'est
toujours la question de la
différenciation des contenus si on fait
la même émission on peut être financé
pareil donc l'avenir du service public
il est dans une
identité propre différente de celle des
chaînes privées parce que ça n'est pas
parce que on a supprimé la redevance
qu'on devrait cesser de lui être
redevable bravo quelle chute merci
beaucoup maître Perrier ça vous a choqué
vous vous propose de Hanouna sur la
télépubique moi je suis
j'ai pas le temps mais j'adorerais faire
un j'ai fait ça avec les dessinateurs du
monde entier mais j'adorerais réunir
tous les journalistes des médias et
comme je vais beaucoup dans les régions
en France et j'entends beaucoup de
critiques sur les médias je voudrais
qu'on revienne sur une réflexion sur la
ligne éditoriale la ligne marketing il y
a des gens qui ont décidé de mettre la
ligne marketing là et la ligne
éditoriale là et je trouve que on
commencerait à s'imposium qui s'appelle
media culpa
viendrait présenter mais il y a plus
qu'à mettre en oeuvre
beaucoup Plantu d'être venu sur le
plateau de LCP merci à vous les
affranchis et merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis merci aussi à toute l'équipe de
Ça vous regarde et de LCP pour cette à
nouveau très belle nouvelle semaine dans
notre jolie écrin c'est le week-end
profitez bien et à dimanche pour ceux
qui aiment la question franco-allemande
[Musique]